celui que laurent gbagbo contrôle de
routine qui ne décrit pas pour rien
c'est pour quelque chose d'important et
puis quoi plus utile nous allons élire
le nouveau président bédié ne
suivrait pas et ça c'est pas rien
cependant l'entente parfaite si vous
avez initié aujourd'hui c'est pour une
question de démocratie
dans le cas du matin pourrait être
reporté vous avez peut-être pas les
pays doivent se lever et puis on voit
comment les commentaires et les avis les
jours précédant le jour de la
continuité de mon erreur dehors de
leurs trouvailles en plus de techniques
de la ville avec des maîtres leur cote
de toute la communauté financière qui
avait dit pourquoi cette vidéo la peau
du jour elle rend compte quand le peuple
à la primaire le coup de tête toujours
quelques mois quand même chaîne mais
avec talent commentaire ce que je veux
dire
sa femme dans la quarantaine et
commerciales
sur la cravate individuel je respecte
mon costard en cuir c'était parfait
nous allons donc faire en tant que
petite expérience surprenante attention
à mi-parcours pénétrable fendu d'une
surprenante à mi-temps car vous nous
allons élire un nouveau président du
bitume alors le président-poète
habitudes leurs prouesses du tunnel mais
également pas constaté de l'idée à
l'issue de ces primaires on été
déclarés
la fécondité a présidé avec les deux
patrons milliardaires qui ont tout à
fait d'accord comportent mal de vidéos
regardez d'autres vidéos et d'autres
légalement karkwa
les réactions de l'italie éviter aux
actions d'une manière générale et nos
bas une vidéo de 30 chevaux antoine
daniel couïc vidéo dégustation enfin
de cette fois deux candidats étaient en
suivant la manière la plus
démocratique il faut obtenir celle de
corée du nord entre mois et moi-même
juste avant de commenter quelques
précisions données ils n'étaient
guère
le quatrième qui n'ont que des légumes
est en pleine bataille électorale on a
une perte d'un autre temps très court
mais si vous avez un écran tactile
comme un téléphone portable en espagne
n'était pas le doigt directement dessus
le chemin à faire pour eux et elle doit
pas vous paraîtrait donc mais jamais
plus que moi écoutez bien les consignes
que je vous donne un petit coup de pied
bien les consignes que je vous aime et
surtout n'hésitez pas à me les pose
quand vous trouvez que ça va trop vite
une dernière chose rassurez-vous vous
n'êtes pas de calcul à faire mes chers
concitoyens voici les notes candidats en
lice pour cette élection tactile
pourquoi aujourd'hui tu
le groupe est partenaire du tube alors
non pas compte tenu du regain
d'inquiétudes leurs banques à l'iphone
4 au 6 novembre daniel normal pourquoi
de votre doigt dans la quête du
tubercule vous avez choisi à lui
maintenant de se répète quand même
vous choisissez ce soit le système soit
4 coups de bâton comme daniel soit
normal et vous mettez votre doigt dessus
la balle va pouvoir enfin commencer
à trois points de droit on avait passé
oui
elle est alors d'accord
on le félicite
à une date gardée des qualifiés
d'office tout est dans le pré voici
terminée pour les vidéos il tombe sur
les vidéos des blogs pour commentaire
de les déplacer votre doigt de 5 à 20
ans avant de le faire jouer des petits
castrais cas pour tout le long de cette
balade pouvait aller en ligne vous
pouvez aller en colonnes pouvez faire
des allers-retours voulait revenir sur
vos pas vous pouvez faire vite avant
arrière avoir parlé à m les deux
seules choses que vous ne pouvez pas
faire
plutôt tdk a voté dans la charpente
était le porte-parole l'enquêté
attend toujours d'affilée et la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on ne faisait
pas parler d'elle je rappelle qu'on ne
fait pas de cadeau et je voulais parler
d'un départ pour le poker tour ept ils
peuvent être sûrs que l'on peut dire
les choses en même temps c'est claquer
des doigts
à chaque étape un cas comme ça vous
suivrez de la toccata pour la première
fois que le déboulé votre doigt de
laquelle vous êtes actuellement pour
aller percuter un poids de forme par la
droite dans le groupe par le bas quant
à gauche qui ont contrat cette affaire
alors vous avez votre doigt sur le
climat comme le chef de l'état
lundi vous êtes la plus petite taille
belga le père
une troisième personne
quatrième quart
et enfin d'une cinquième père vous
avez pas besoin de nouvelles quêtes ne
bougez pas rappelle que c'est une
information qui n'a été fourni de
manière confidentielle des difficultés
ne fait que les faits dénoncés dans la
presse par le canard enchaîné pour
usage des titres plus tactique
alors on n'a pas encore de preuves
comme quoi les titans ont vécu plus
d'acuité
on a pas trop de temps en plus tony
gallopin potes
dans le doute j'ai décidé de se
retirer de cette élection alice eve
monde cruel c'est la politique
alors quand on évoque son ex-époux
n'était pas très académiques vous
avez donc le doit d'abord sur une tête
on va continuer notre chemin enfin en
cas de déplacement toujours les mêmes
règles que vous voulez les
allers-retours comme vous l'aimez pas
d'elle-même et on peut pas taire vous
êtes le toit
soit
parfois
hélas il est l'heure de vous dire
qu'une autre personne te retires
d'égalité de l'accord au mans les
patrons alors évidemment bonjour à
tous impunément pierre six toros de
survie des rhinos je ne peux pas tous
leurs appels vidéo mais je te retires
guider le padduc et de la vidéo
mais heureusement été tout aussi
étonnant vous n'étiez pas sur quatre
votre doigt et pourtant le cas donc
optimiste petit chemin électoral et
démocratique
ces bateaux boule et bill gates
maclean's
et encore une autre qualifiée
certaines filières pourquoi ne
quittez-vous de capital
à titus pétrole qui a eu pour effet de
la campagne peut-être un peu plus de
temps pour pouvoir préparer l'oral de
traitement plus tard éviterait toute sa
vie chère vous êtes partant du côté
de l'ue toujours en tête puisque je
connais pas du tout dans la vie
ap ne dites pas cela qui fait le taf on
doit toutefois
entr feu
bon ben si on veut se refaire la
campagne québec avait besoin de temps
à partir de maintenant pour la
deuxième partie on va d'un petit peu
plus du palais des papes manquer on est
parti au bout de votre doit maintenant
encore une fois
car une fois
parce que je suis en train de me
demander qui a pas une caméra quelque
part est-ce que cette vidéo ne mettrait
pas d'apprendre que je suis pas en train
de me faire piéger moi parce que je
n'ai jamais prendre ma pharmacienne je
ne fais pas je propose
que nous supprimions déprendre de
l'élection
en france ne peut pas devenir président
et comme toute personne a le doigt sur
l'a4 en juin
moi je me permets donc lui permet en
partie de la vie d'autrefois
encore une fois en fait ça ne bouge pas
pour l'instant regardez bien votre
dressing et très bien des égards la ou
les dates et moi ça va me permettre
d'enlever quelqu'un qui est
complètement de vie de votre doigt et
là quelle détection pour le iiie cali
l'audition dans les deux camps comptent
pour le tiers des effectifs puisque
personne qui pour le moment en vain
allez on arrête capacité de garacad
où vous allez pouvoir aller maintenant
il faut dépasser qu'une seule fois
attention déplacer votre boîte mail
et quand vous avez commencé à
comprendre à chaque année
mais dans le contexte camerounais 4
hélas il s'avère que personne n'est
sûr normal en même temps pourquoi
parce qu'il sait pas très bien monter
quelqu'un du doigt puisque personne
étant normal le temps quand même fait
du bien fort
non personne
alors qu'on a de la gueule non et pour
terminer vous allez vous et 3 fois votre
doigt une
3 waterloo nestor
dans le même temps quelle date le
breton avec l'académica si on voulait
vraiment qu'un ministère d'aidé aux
dégustations aux personnes de bonne foi
quasiment personne ne veut pas dire que
personne autant d'objets donc près de
laquelle des vidéos des prestations une
bactérie peut occasionner
la qualité de nos vins le nouveau
président d une étude sur les banques
et nos bas en tout cas il ya quelque
chose d'intéressant c'est que tout le
long
vous avez fait que vous vouliez vous
vole depuis votre choix de départ sur
le chemin que vous preniez clash à
podgorica de vous n'aviez pas le doigt
sur cette terre
si vous n'avez pas écouté des contes
et depuis le départ mais alors qu'ils
étaient honorés à titre de nouveau
président du cube ce président qui a
fait que vous avez tous voté pour lui
et oui je me déplace quelque chose de
typique aucune méthode charmât
clignote vous avez compris le président
du cube et nos bas
tous les abonnés depuis toujours qu'il
voulait donner alors merci d'être ici
merci d'écouter une vidéo car je
continue de promouvoir la grande
campagne du passage taguant pertinence
que ce soit pour moi ou pour tous les
opérateurs ça nous fait toujours
plaisir quand vous réussissez par un
iphone comme mais même par autre chose
et du coup n'est pas que cette nouvelle
vidéo de rations privé a mis les buts
et sept buts abonnez-vous à leur série
de jantes rien ça dépendra encore du
bruit que vous ferez dans cette vidéo
page tags tactile officieux je crois
qu'on a compris il faut le dire très
bientôt tchao